T-shirts! Get your T-shirts!
And the White House
is called
the People's House,
because in America,
the government
works for you.
Bullshit!
Listen up, kids!
Everything they teach you
in school is a lie!
You want the truth?
The world is controlled by
shadowy elites
and shapeshifting
lizard people!
Have you ever folded
a one-dollar bill?
Look!
You can make it say "boobs"!
What does it mean?!
Am I the only one
who cares that the President
is a robot?!
Wake up, sheeple!
The evidence is right here!
These sons of bitches
got snipers trained on me
for trying to
tell you the truth!
Ah, I love being right.
Thank you!
Take a flyer, for a friend!
Dad, what the fuck?
Has retirement made you go
completely insane?
No, but the 5G radio waves
in the air have,
which you can read all about
in my new manifesto,
available on Kindle.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Don't listen
to my father, kids!
He gets his news from
Facebook and Ambien.
Ambien's a great drug.
Really clarifies
some things.
Come on, I'm late for work.
Democracy is real!
Have some keychains.
Hey, Reagan.
Let's go to the mall
and get a Wetzel's pretzel.
They got those ones with
the cheese inside the crust.
Dad, I know
retirement is tough,
but there's
more positive ways
to get my attention than
"taking down
the deep state."
Besides, today, I am finally
getting that promotion!
Imagine it.
Me, ruling the office
with an iron fist!
I even programmed
an iron fist!
I've seen better.
Oh, have you seen better?
Alright, that's pretty good.
Yeah, that is
pretty good, huh?
Welcome to Cognito, Inc.
We are a company.
We are…
Good morning, Dr Ridley.
We are a company.
Look, Dad, as long as
you're living with me,
we need some ground rules.
First, no more
vodka for breakfast.
Aw, come on!
You can't tell people that
the government isn't real.
But it's not!
Dr Ridley?
You can't talk about
shapeshifting reptiles.
-Good morning, Senator!
-Revenues, and, uh…
You can't tell people
the weather is controlled
by Gerald from Accounting,
or that the Dow Jones
is controlled
by blood sacrifices.
Shares of JPMorgan Chase
up 14 points!
Whoo!
Rules, rules, rules.
When did this become
such a boring place to work?
Morning, Dr Ridley!
-Hi, Steve.
Fucking brown-noser.
And most importantly,
you absolutely
cannot tell people
that we're replacing
the President
with a robot, okay?
Ah, don't be so uptight.
Uptight? You almost
exposed the deep state
because you wanted
a ride to Wetzel's Pretzels!
You're lucky
I called the snipers off!
Gary, no. No!
Ha ha. Save it for
stand-up night, Gary.
Shit, I'm late.
Hey! Intern guy.
Take my dad home.
If he gives you trouble,
don't be afraid to
lightly tase him.
Do it, I fucking dare you.
You know who I am? I'm
Rand motherfucking Ridley,
and I used to
run this company.
And soon,
I will be running it.
Nothing higher than a three!
Later, Dad!
Motherfucker!